l'hélicoptère le jet ski sont
régulièrement employée pour sauver des
vies humaines sur les plages cette année
sur la côte basque les pompiers
sauveteurs ont reçu un nouvel équipement
une planche de surf appelé le paddle
board
daigneault ville guy saba comme tous les
étés sur la place du centre à bidart les
milliers de baigneurs joue dans les
vagues
pendant que sur la plage leurs anges
gardiens veillent sur eux mais pour
cette année des pompiers sauveteurs ont
ajouté à leur panoplie à nouveau moyen
de sauvetage très efficaces qu'ils ont
rapporté des plages du pacifique
ali baddou a déjà confié
cet objet s'appelle de paddle board en
français la plancha ramé ce sauveteur
est l'un de ceux qui l'ont introduit en
france c'est un habitué des plages
d'australie cet hiver à sydney il a
disputé les championnats du monde de
sauvetage la planche mesure trois mètres
de long et pèse 5 kg sa grande
flottabilité lui permet de supporter
plusieurs adultes
d'abord c'est ni plus ni moins qu'une
planche de surf
ça a été adapté au sauvetage qui a été
employée depuis depuis le temps à royan
en australie pour les récupérer les
surfers trop avantage par exemple très
curieux zone relativement plane
notamment dans une baïne c'est à dire
une zone où il ya un fort courant
le paddle board va avancer très
rapidement
et vu le volume on peut aussi accroché
beaucoup de personnes au large quitte à
attendre ensuite d'autres moyens
d'évacuation comme l'hélicoptère ou le
jet ski
d'autres moyens pour l'instant l'engin
est importé d'australie où il a fait ses
preuves et cette planche de salut
devrait bientôt s'imposer en france pour
offrir aujourd'hui si vous travaillez
sur nos plages bon il faut qu'ils
maîtrisent de plusieurs techniques de
sauvetage aisance technique pouvant
circuler filin aujourd'hui et tapis chez
nous et puis aussi des nouvelles
techniques et notamment effectivement le
paddle et dont nous on commence équipe
que tout oppose avec le type de nouveaux
moyens une planche vos trois mille
francs à ce prix là le paddleboard avec
son beau surfeur vont bientôt donner un
look très australien aux plages
françaises